from parking to traffic to people
waiting in the heat to get their
vaccination verifications it was a busy
game day madison kimbrough now
continuing our team coverage with how
fans took to the changes over at
allegion
yeah in the past couple months we have
seen a plethora of problems plague
allegiant stadium that you see right
behind me from parking issues to
concession stand problems but tonight
nothing but good vibes from fans as they
were pleased with how smoothly
everything seemed to go
raider nation turned out monday evening
for the first home game of the season
and from the looks of it people came
prepared whether that meant leaving
early to find parking or making sure
they had all their vaccination
credentials in order i thought it was a
pretty easy day except for
the walk because i'm old we showed them
our
vaccine passport and our tickets got in
got right to our seats everybody was
really helpful nice
it was a good experience my husband went
to the game
i came out here
to represent
raiders nation happy excitement and just
walk around while several fans were
dropped off to avoid the long traffic
lines and expensive parking some decided
to stick with seasoned parking passes
and say it was well worth it for them we
put our car over here at the express
and they charged us out of dollars
and we came in early to park it they
were really good there too
so i mean everything so far not gonna
look for us has been really really good
for anyone worried about waiting in the
heat there are water stations set up
around the stadium and fans do say it's
best to upload your vaccination info to
the clear health pass app ahead of game
day do it ahead of time because there's
just things that might go wrong
so
just be prepared
now some viewers shared that they had
some issues with the clear app you can
call the number up on your screen that's
855-253-2763 or you can go to
clearme.com
support for further help reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now